Let's dive in a little deeper into this whole concept of edges.
But let's now look at images and derivatives of images.
So I'd like to define an edge basically as a point in an image, pixel or
group of pixel but there is a rapid change in the im, image intensity function.
So basically again we want to look at, the image intensities, at a three
pixel value, in a discrete form or in a function across the function itself.
And look for where there is any kind of rapid change.
Significant change.
Again the rapid change will somewhere where the threshold value will come in.
Small gradual change will be a few pixels, but also not just looking at
how one pixel to the other but a significant size of the neighborhood.
Just to keep things simple we're going to look at just the one
slice through this image.
This is a sample image that we will play with here.
And if I was to just construct of course,
the slice of this intensity, I would get this.
So in essence, as I traverse through an image, the intensity is high.
Where this grey values are.
Goes down to a little whole number but it's darker and then comes back up.
So this is basically, on this slice is the intensity map.
Here's what we want to do to this now data here, this the intensity map.
We want to actually just do a simple difference operation on it.
That is I want to take, for example, this value and
difference it from the next one coming after it.
And then similarly I want to basically each and
every value, I want to difference it from the previous one.
This is basically a simple first derivative by just doing simple differences.
And if you look at this, and actually if you look at this kind of stuff here
too, there is of course no changes here, and all of a sudden, many comes here.
There is a significant change.
This would of course when you look at it in difference form,
would give you this change of course.
When it gets here, it basically goes back to zero again, no change.
Another way to look at it, this would be for
example the slope of this line, the slope of this line is zero.
All of a sudden the slope goes from zero to a larger number and
then of course goes back to zero again.
So when you notice here, goes to larger number, goes back to zero.
Similarly when we come back to here, it's this way and again the slope changes.
End of this line again, comes back to zero.
So if you notice this is an interesting phenomenon,
that we will actually now capture.
This point here is basically an output of information that
cames from this region here.
And this region here was captured by this point.
So if you notice now, is, these extrema points refer to this edge, and
this extrema point refers to this edge.
We'll only look for derivatives in x, and these are the two edges.
But there's a rapid change.
As I traverse this way on the image.
Of course, using this now edges,
we would be able to find something that would always be similar.
Even if I actually took the image of this one slightly moved around to
a next part, or if this was translated in some way.